foreign
are we going yet no not yet
[Music]
got it
that's why we need a BTS cam you got
um
[Music]
but also if we're starting
I don't know do you guys do like a start
like welcome I don't know you just did
it that was that good started yeah a
good start welcome yeah welcome to the
dungeon we got fun and games our buddy
uh Rick Glassman in the city whoo
back out
uh cut snipped moist yes
your hair can handle this weather yeah I
look at my hair like a cake I like it to
be you know moist
sweet
dark and I want to put it in my mouth
yeah yeah it'll come all over it yeah
that's important outside sitting on
girls sitting on cakes oh yeah yeah I
started it really no no but it's a site
it's a I made you like started washing
it no it's a uh fetish oh is that you
thought you may start it like I just
started watching Suits yeah
that's what I was going for well I get
you thank you yeah man well uh it's
great to have you here yeah tell it to
your face
I don't know if you reveal this kind of
stuff but you said you know just done a
podcast and I just did a podcast and
we're all a little bit like at least I
am yeah so you're like happy you're here
yeah
the pockets of the new gym like I don't
even work out anymore I just do pods all
day and I'm like exhausted yeah I often
look at gyms like cakes like I love them
you just can't have them too much and I
prefer when they're black yeah they're
moist yeah from the uh the sweat before
you come all over them yeah when are we
starting
oh no was that oh is that on for real
oh man we gotta delete all that no oh my
God good to see you there that [__] stuff
could get you canceled oh yeah better
coming than going
there's still a place called come and go
it's a fan yeah I started it
it's a fanny backpack oh it's back it's
it offers a great utility and I'm not
going to decide what is back and what
isn't when it offers me stuff I just did
another podcast my arms are tired and I
have external hard drives I have my
sunglasses and my headphones that's you
know it's too little for a backpack
right too much for my pockets
um
it's a Purgatory you're in a limbo gray
area Middle Ground like my cake yeah
cake that's a no gray hair good band
yeah which one cake oh yeah they got
some stuff oh I love that yeah they were
good they were good but what's going on
here they're baggy seems to be in these
clothes are flowier than a loose labia
careful okay you look very you look hip
without trying I feel like oh he's
trying
cake
you know moist black and you want to
come all over me yeah
I don't find a white cake
what do you call that vanilla yeah yeah
just grabbing their tits yeah I'm
grabbing the cake I like this because
this is unlike our other guests yeah
this is a different energy and I love it
did you like the other energy too no
well we don't we won't say who it is no
his name rhymes with block Morphin I hit
that out again I had an idea
I was trying to do a name but clearly
you're not going to figure out who it is
oh okay okay I thought if I said mavid
Wade you would know who I was talking
about
David Spade I was thinking Dwyane Wade
oh geez we're all we're all our periods
aren't synced do me a favor just for the
sake of like people wanting to watch the
rest of this start it now
[Music]
thank you are we starting now okay wow
you could keep holding it all right keep
it in you heard him boys it's good to be
back yeah good to have you back hey you
got your own merch oh yeah look at you
well then we're back that's not that's
not the only merch I got for us you guys
already have them but I never gave you
your own so we'll do that on here
because I told you about him on here not
these gay cards yeah
don't we have is this what we have
framed right here yeah oh if you don't
like it if you didn't want to set for
yourselves and let's not worry about it
I want a [__] set I'll sell them at a
pawn shop well if you don't I I mean no
one's gonna buy it but I'd love to have
the kids give us the [__] card dude
yeah it's merch all right I'll take out
my uh vaccine card and I'll put that in
its place
we don't need those anymore who are you
I don't know
do you know him yet yeah yeah yeah I
know him how would you describe him oh
geez what are we doing therapy this
feels like couples there you are a
pastry how would you describe a pastry
okay that like a croissant he's flaky
all right let's draw his [__] he's dry
man he's only good in the mornings but
I'm always happy to see him
hey how would you describe him as a
pastry a baked good well Bagel is the
easy out you know with the uh semitism
um pause Pro but uh let's see hypnotism
nonetheless yeah Semite you don't hear
too much about pro-semitism no you don't
uh pastry I would go uh English no no
that's not a pastry I don't think it's
anything that's baked English muffin
English muffin because it's a it's every
you can have one every day but it's also
a little classier oh you know thank you
but you could also put a horse [__] on
it you know you could put you know uh
Cheetos and and peanut butter so you can
go either way English muffins do you
make yeah
I was thinking of something kind of down
and dirty I love an English muffin okay
you like a croissant
I got into croissants maybe two years
ago if that I never liked them because I
don't really like butter and they taste
butter oh that's the best part well I
got into them and then I started eating
them every day every day like I was like
I want to go get a coffee
and I didn't always get a coffee four
days a week but I would always walk to
the place and I want to look at the
croissants
did I fart no you didn't just fart did
you hear that
I didn't hear it his body just makes
sound I just I said I love croissant
look at you and I just hear I I had a it
was the couch there's a girl I'm seeing
and I farted and uh she goes to do far
and I said no but I did yeah and I lied
you know and then she goes and then I
was like all right I did and she goes
well now I can't trust you and I was
like that like that's you know
indicative of all of my behavior like as
if I cheat on her and it's the same way
I would respond to a fart yeah like did
you cheat on me and I'd be like yes
would you rather tell her that you
cheated than you farted if you did both
I think you got to tell both that's what
she's saying that's what she's saying I
get it but I don't think it's a
different
yeah it's a different level the far are
you not comfortable farting in front of
your girl no I am I was just trying to
be silly with it you know is she cool
with it
yeah but I think here's the thing you
should be comfortable with it but you
shouldn't get greedy with it oh kind of
like uh with great power comes great
responsibility absolutely you're like
the Spider-Man yeah because the Venom
taiso cards.com I'll send you a picture
there you go but yeah I fart in front of
the lady and you're right I get greedy
sometimes I'm like does she think it's
funny she does it with the first toot
and then if I really
elephantitis
that she's not into well it's hard to
segue that into being like you want to
go to the bedroom yeah you can't you
gotta you gotta keep the romance alive
yeah we're not doing it in the bedroom
that's what I've that's what I let them
fly the Dutch oven I know it's childish
but it's [__] amazing is that
cultural appropriation yeah to fart
under the covers if you're not Dutch a
good point a little different with a Jew
too real insensitive what do you mean
wow that's some history there what are
you saying the Dutch I love the Dutch
what we said about Bagels
oh but farting goes either way I uh
um my girl and I uh we met
um what's his name
what would it matter you said that my
cards were gay that that I'm gay what do
you have against gay people I wish I was
gay well you can be it is a choice
but uh my girl poor guy and I uh before
we even met because we met online and
it's a long distance and we would face
time all the time what app uh wasn't a
nap
you meant on Instagram just I went I
found her business
nice um uh and by the way her business
um as far as this concern is none your
business oh what have I given too much
away in my personal life those nachos
because this is not your business okay
that was a thing when I was a kid no I
remember nacho cheese yeah there's a
restaurant where I'm from and they're
called not so fries because they're not
like your typical fries and I would
always think like whose fries are these
they're not so fries ah
better than Nazi for us yeah those are
bad fries
not good it's crazy burnt to a crisp
yeah all right
you know I had a comic say to me
recently I because I posted a clip or a
guy said perform Jew and he is a heavier
comic and he goes uh would you get that
a lot he yelled out performed Jew trying
to be funny oh when I reached it I'm
sorry ah yeah bless you I'm really um
I'm really feeling myself forcing a
couple of jokes in here don't force but
I want to make sure I have a safe space
to force the jokes
use the force I don't know if we've had
one good one yet but we're good
but I want to hear about this uh who is
the heavier guy and he goes you get the
Jew thing along stage like no night's
very rare and he goes you know because
sometimes people yell out of me that I'm
fat ah I don't think what's different
isn't it I mean first off there's never
been a fat Holocaust true you know
they'd be harder to hide well the Jews
are running it'll be a holocaust can we
keep that one in
keep it in
Hollywood we've reviewed it yeah I guess
a personal trainer is kind of like a
genocide for fat people
but you're paying for it you don't pay
for a genocide I guess you're right yeah
but we're still paying for it we are and
it wasn't that wasn't also not our
choice true good point but you guys are
obsessed with paying um what are you
doing all right sorry I'm sorry keep
going can we go can we do can we do uh
Rick is bad first day Rick you're you're
great at improv can you do a scene where
your mark is getting disciplined for
making pedophile jokes you work at an
office
so he's not a comedian he's not a
comedian you're in a you're you're HR
okay Mark is uh
um
where does he work Allah office God
Mark's a lawyer yeah they're perfect I'm
a lawyer I've been re-watching suits
um well I founded it and uh I get it I
get this stuff so okay so uh you will be
an associate or maybe a junior partner
sure and I uh in HR or I'm an upper a
lawyer that is like yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right so I'm the new your name's on
the door you're a [__] I'm a name
partner sure I'm a name partner I'll
tell you we had a couple of Girl Scouts
trying to sell us cookies I'd like to
get in that little box
okay
oh yeah boy we're pretty close to a
playground huh anyone else hard
oh okay well Halloween's coming up baby
I'm gonna have a big uh chocolate bar
for that kid real Payday hey Mark yeah
yeah have you heard my my pedophile
stuff it's it's doing okay yeah we've
all heard your pedophile stuff mark
a couple of people in the office they've
been talking oh good I'm getting some
Buzz going uh and you've been making
people feel uncomfortable oh
they heard my stuff
it's pretty good
what what have you been telling oh I got
a bunch of a kid [__] joke let me
hear something I love Michael Jackson uh
uh I would kill I wish I could have gone
to Epstein's Island that's actually it's
okay okay but it's still not appropriate
for the office and also there's been a
rumor going around here that um
could you close the door for a sec oh
god
um a ruler going around that you didn't
actually go to Harvard
no no I went to preschool okay there's
the show all right what do you think
that was a pretty good coming to Hulu
yeah
um coming to Disney plus
all right so when I first uh when like
my girl and I first started talking one
of the first things we talked about
before we met was and it was silly but
like in intentional and also mattered
where are you with farting like how are
you I I fart I have to fight oh good and
um some people think it's disgusting
some people think it's hilarious and
everywhere in between uh I have noticed
and I I don't think it's a coincidence
and my relationships over the years
they've all been okay with farting and I
think it's indicative of like if you're
not okay with farting farts aside I
don't know if you'll be okay with me
just expressing myself however I need to
sure and she thinks farting's funny she
farts all the time wow lady fart uh very
much a lady fart like it like an English
muffin very classy yeah that was not a
classy far that was a dying fart right
it was more of a puff yeah
and it's a hard stop it's a cute fart uh
no they're just well you know she's
wonderful and everything is wonderful
but they are I'm here her farts are way
stinkier than mine oh that's a problem
but she she has great fart timing okay
she's great first time and she she'll uh
she'll get up and go are we hearing
these farts I'm hearing these farts no
but I got you hold on let me see
yeah that's what I've been hearing
very impressive but she'll make a little
joke out of it she'll go over there and
be like I have to go make a phone call
you know whatever her version that is
I'm like he gets a laugh I know what
she's doing she does it over there yeah
I just I love
my grandfather used to say it's better
to Belch and bear the shame than not to
Belch and bear the pain hey and I
subscribe to that very much he was in
the Holocaust yeah he knows about gas
well all right
but good for her I my ladies let a few
of those lady poofs go and uh it's
off-putting
yeah yeah I know it's a double standard
there but it is a little off-putting the
noise or the smell or both the smell
right I can deal with the Noah I love a
fart noise like her so much do you like
your wife I'm up and down right I'm in
and out hot and cold off and on yeah
straightened by but
too much it's like you said you can't
get greedy with the farts you let one go
at the right time hey dad's funeral
now we're cooking funeral farts are
solid oh it's a lot of tension exactly
yeah they're right it's an open yeah
you're cutting the basket with a fart
yeah you can't do it you know when the
they're putting the dirt on the casket
like at a Jewish funeral don't fart at
that moment right so unless you have to
fart at that moment well yeah then you
have to but that's why those poofs are
good because they're they're a little
quieter so you know Andy kozell he's a
la comedian he's uh he said something
once I farted at Barney's Beanery or
something and it was like we gotta laugh
out of it uh and he said uh farts have
the best comedic timing and I've always
like when have you heard a fart and even
if you're grossed out by like it's funny
it's funny Blazing Saddles is on TV
yesterday and I turned on right at the
fart scene oh the beans The Nutty
Professor fart scene fart scenes are
funny you can't I think the fart they
said was the first joke in like caveman
time it was like a guy's ass with a
puff of wind coming out I thought that
was we adapted to speak we used to speak
out of our butts and that was talking
lines
now you're just talking out of your ass
yeah cut to a clip of Ace Ventura part
two hey Nature Calls all right but yeah
farting with a relationship it's kind of
like the abortion issue you gotta be on
one side of it yeah are you pro-choice
or are you uh
Pro
stink yeah I think it is like the
abortion issue I'm okay when a man
decides to do it right yeah so the
government is in their ass now as well
yeah right pro-life dude how do you feel
when a guy farts around you when it
smells or oh yeah that's annoying right
it's look one is funny it's when you get
greedy it's we've been around the guy
like micro scenes far they might be the
worst farts I've ever smelled in my life
he ruins your day he hot boxes you
they're in the room they don't go
usually they linger then they go away
but he's always farting you're saying
well Foodies you got you gotta think
like people who love like I love Chinese
food but you got to think like certain
things you eat are gonna make your gas
smell I mean yeah
Play-Doh yeah but
you've been with those people that we
were like what is your diet right that
this is coming out of you while we're on
diets I'd like to follow up because last
time we spoke that you were Pepto-Bismol
all the time and then I think I got you
on to the peppermint oil are you did you
we have a very interesting friendship I
feel like we're friends now right yeah
what are you kidding absolutely but it's
such an interesting question that I'm
actually flattered that you asked yeah I
want to hear more about it well the fact
that you turn me I was a Pepto-Bismol
guy to the point that it was in my rider
so Pepto was in my Mateo Lane the
comedian once texted me thank God I'm at
this club after you because there's
Pepto in the garage yeah but I told him
Rick Glassman turned me off Pepto I'm
doing the peppermint pills now and much
better natural it's it's better for you
interesting and they work don't they but
it's how bad is your stomach how often
because you are you asked if I had any
when you came so I have digestive
enzymes on me so like I'm I'm trying to
be more conscious of what I've learned
what doesn't feel good for me
um so I've I'm doing a better job at
what doesn't feel good
well fried foods
um don't I I do have a I've learned that
gluten doesn't necessarily affect my
stomach but affects my joints like I get
stuck and H gluten causes inflammation
for a lot of people yeah
um so when I eat gluten if I eat fried
food if I eat a dessert huh um wow
that's a lot of foods that's why I try
and limit them
um but when I do I take a digestive
enzyme not necessarily a peppermint pill
once my stomach starts to not even
painful once I start to feel in my
stomach or something I'll take a green
pill right away and it's like magic
really oh yeah is that the green pills
oh yeah oh wow IB guard yeah it's good
stuff which is like out of all my
sponsors I want to get an I want to
invest into IB guards yeah the guy
because I talk I I sell it I mean HIV
guard that's just a condom but I gotta
get some of this for my wife because
she's got the stomach of of uh the
Jewish people yeah it's not pretty today
is not Jewish now I wish but no should
be circumcised but she's uh always got
the stomach stuff she's like well my
stomach lactose listen peppermint pill
great but obviously she's she doesn't
know what's affecting her body like yeah
and the semen intake is overwhelming
really wonderful oh my God like it's
mayonnaise yeah um that was part of his
toast at the wedding it was beautiful
yeah
we cheers yeah
um yeah I guess that would be a man's
age
now would you say that she gets stomach
aches all the time or would you say that
she has them uh all the time and she's
[__] like a goose it's wet it's
bloody it's gay it's wild wait a minute
you should not have good stereotypes
that like she said it Loose he's had a
goose not juice [__] like a goose oh you
heard juice from Goose I heard Jews okay
he said stomach could be Goose goose
like she shits like a goose but she has
a stomach of a Jew right that's what I
mean yeah yeah that's the modern day
Frankenstein's monster right stomach of
a Jew face of a goose yeah
I think uh what's her face looks like a
goose uh
uh what's her name you know what I'm
talking about the lady if we guess now
it's just gonna be hurtful every Goose
now Goose face she's pretty but she's
got the face of a goose what's his name
who actress yeah he was in a new movie
he was in Barbie Ryan Gosling
we'll be right back which one's my
camera this one
this one
oh Sarah Jessica Parker no no that looks
like a goose you looked up actress
famous actress maybe not Sarah she's in
the movie but the um the little boy
where they got they gave her some [__]
for being too weird because she's
[__] a little boy oh Jennifer
Lawrence Lawrence Goose you don't see
Goose no I feel like she's got a little
Goose face going put a goose up
type in Jennifer Lawrence he looks like
a goose hold on a hot goose oh we don't
want that
uh well I'm standing right there on the
right I mean she's very attractive I
think you don't see the goose at all
there's like a little neck thing going
on no oh there she is oh that's a goose
oh oh okay got it all right well maybe
it's just me I see Goose I don't see
that you see geese in a lot of things no
never
mind
no no you hear Jew he says he's
therapist scene yeah oh man so Mark um
look at that goose
come on
there you go we got this that's just the
worst picture of her that's not all
right I see uh squawken White feathered
goo
B that's a Paltrow's company
vagina candle what click on that one
with the Gray's dress by the way that's
just a [__] hourglass I've ever seen
one Hachi Machi who is that that's her
oh wow she looks good little Goose on
the left hot on the right that sounds
like a lyric to something we got Goose
on the left
right walking all day [__] all night
all night anyway now that's the goose
with the short hair look at that
[Laughter]
all right so I'm sorry I cut I cut
through there with the goose what were
you guys talking about I'm just saying
my girl's fart timing is pretty good oh
fart timing but let's talk about what
you said that you think we're friends
out
is it because you're not sure if I feel
the same
I said I'm not yeah I don't know we
don't talk a ton but I feel like I'm
always happy to see you I thought it was
a given you've done the party you've
been in his Green Room you've done our
pod 900 times you're right I think that
was solidified once we're hanging
outside a pod is you know yeah if you
guys ever get Jennifer Lawrence as a
guest that's that's over now uh I want
you to uh get up and go around the room
and tap everyone else's head and say
duck ah and then we get to her oh see if
she knows a reference I thought I had
bad add this guy said let's get back to
our friendship and then he goes back to
the goose thing the goose joke locked
and loaded he wanted to give it out you
know the duck duck goose just came in
right now oh okay maybe because
friendship kids games right well maybe
that was just why don't you stop playing
games with me dude oh yeah you're
playing Goosebumps okay jeez
good children's book Goosebumps remember
that RL Stein yeah oh gee yeah yeah I
don't think I've ever finished a book
that wasn't a Goosebumps for real there
you go what about the Torah I didn't
finish it but I did read my portion oh
okay
yikes it's a beautiful language which
means my stomach hurts you have any
green pills yeah
yeah so so yeah because our relationship
the the my relationship with the two of
you is uh I think exclusively
with the exception of when we did just
for last together a while ago oh wow
which was 2013. yeah 14. years
um we were just back though it was weird
to be back yeah did you open with that
or did you say good to be back weird to
be bad where to be back where to be back
yeah uh it was Sam is um
podcast is our friendship so like most
of our friendship is like documented if
not all of it that's right except for
that [__]
[Music]
what was that I was giving a high five
to the mannequin okay
okay good but uh so you're saying that
we're friends the way porn stars who
only [__] unsetter lovers no I'm saying
I understand why you would question that
oh okay but uh I have developed very
both grown friendships and created
friendships through podcasting
um where like I knew a person and now
some of them are become like my best
friends uh you we don't live in the same
place but like I feel like
I feel like we've absolutely become
friends yeah from it me too hold on my
uh I'll get out of here Cliffy friend
alarm is going off you guys done yet
that was beautiful but uh but like yeah
I don't know you outside like we don't
have an I don't know you outside of
Performing yeah you know like even this
as low energy as it is low energy I'm on
my toes here that's funny because I
believe you and I'm just so used to
being so [__] hyper that I feel like
I gotta match you 80d cuts and it ain't
easy I'm
well your lawyer improv was good okay
let's do another one what should we do I
don't have improving you're a master at
it I appreciate that but really I'm just
here to to facilitate you know
elephant what
[Music]
by the way I went and saw a safari went
into the Safari elephants with the
meanest animals everybody's like the
Lions what are we gonna do elephants
charge this every two minutes do you
think it's because you don't stop making
fun of them maybe I did some weight
jokes yeah what happens next time you
see Jennifer Lawrence how do you think
she's gonna feel oh man she's gonna Peck
me is that weird too that this [__] will
live forever and there is a chance you
will meet her I've hung out with her oh
wait yeah at our wedding she was
half in the bag so she won't remember
how would she look I mean she looked
great oh drunk does that mean drunk yeah
Kyle Dunnigan was all over how'd he do
not good he was trying to seal the deal
with some Caitlyn Jenner yeah yeah he
tried his Bill Maher okay
okay people all right why would you ever
have kids okay and then uh he did his
buy do you think Bill Maher is
condescending while he's [__] women
he's like really really
what are you saying what huh oh that's
and we have our cold open
so what are you saying what it's like
dude what is this I don't know we're all
over the road but Bill Maher what I was
saying what are you saying about are you
talking about somebody's impression of
him are you actually talking about no
Kyle Donegan does an incredible Bill
Maher have you never seen that I have
seen it it's excellent it's funny as
hell but he's saying is Bill Mark [__]
while or condescending while [__]
I was trying to set up an improv for you
possibly okay you be Bill Maher okay
oh yeah why would you ever have kids it
seems all right all right but mine was
nice okay that was some good improv from
both of you I'm a big fan of his he just
had Riley Gaines on the the swimmer lady
who hates oh nice whatever Tom yeah I
like I like his show a lot and Bill
Marshall yeah new rules is it's great
it's incredible and his delivery of it
and what he brings to it and also the
writers of that are I love it I love it
too it's items it gets me for real I get
like [__] yeah we you know like real
riled up like it's funny and and
poignant yes I'm a bill Marshall fan
yeah it's good I like him too he's smug
as [__] but you you learn to love him
um I I watched uh him with Bill Maher uh
Bill Burr oh that was weird that was an
uncomfortable one yeah and I asked Phil
about it because
and
hand oh sorry hand job
um because I'm uh because Bill Maher
often on his show
and I understand it but he seems that to
have an agenda against ageism pretty
strongly he does hate that like
not you know what that Meme I don't need
to explain what ageism means oh [__]
um
do we hate agents
turn it off dude all right sir and um
Bill said something about like there are
different Generations or I don't know 15
years apart or whatever and
he goes you're
there was such contention between Bill
Mard like with the age of I don't even
remember what it was but like it was
kind of like we went like it was and
built up no no everything was fine he
thought it was totally comfortable yeah
but like is that I was a little
uncomfortable watching yeah you saw it
right yeah and I obviously they're both
you know different and great bills
um
but it was like uncomfortable and build
and feel it at all which is weird I read
it a little bit as I think with a
stand-up Bill Maher is a little insecure
because I think he thinks he's one of
the greatest stand-ups ever he says that
he says that and it's
I mean come on there's no world where
he's in the same class as Bill Burr it's
it's insane I mean I agree as a stand-up
I'm saying you know his show is terrific
yeah right but I think there's a little
insecurity and he's a little feels
challenged by a guy that's how I read it
it's his show so he was kind of he kept
interrupting him he was kind of trying
to Alpha Burr a little bit that's how I
feel like Burr is so good at getting
back in and you can't you can't [__]
with him so it was awkward I mean with
bird
yeah I I thought he was trying to Big
Dog him a little bit that's what I'm
saying maybe I have very and it's just
not gonna happen you're just not gonna
pull it off on him but he's too quick
and he's too confident and he's too good
it's it's not gonna happen and he's kind
of pulled to like what are you doing man
you had me on your show you won't let me
talk and Mar has to go ah jeez all right
it was on Bill's show unless they both
did it I didn't watch are you talking
about on Bill Burr's podcast or Bill
Mars podcast it was on real time it was
on HBO
oh we're talking about two different
things I don't even see that he's on the
Pod Bill Maher came on Bill Burr's
podcast is that right yeah how did I
miss that pull that up the audio
and right I don't know whatever well he
doesn't have video but uh yeah he does
but it was weird again because Bill Burr
what came on my podcast right after that
so and he said and it was it was weird
again Bill Burr didn't say it was weird
I thought it was a little content well
he's not going to admit to him he seemed
to Bill seem to be being honest oh it is
on video I guess they started to oh I
gotta listen to this when was this 22 oh
this is a almost a year old geez I'm out
of the loop
um
but uh yeah so age you know coming I
mean if you want to leave this [__] in
the podcast go for it but holy [__] I
almost fell asleep yeah well it was your
idea yeah I dropped the ball all right
we took a risk I get it I'm feeling
Stellar this has nothing to do with me
yeah we're just searching Stellar yeah
that Google stinks there's some real
idiots over there in siliconville are
you guys worried about AI take it over
uh comedy
I'm worried about AI period yeah it's
all it's all going to be a period i
period yeah yeah yeah I'm worried about
it man no it's uh
I think we got a good five years left so
we better we better live I think tour
like a [__] cash is going away
too
yeah that worries me I like cash what do
you like about cash well the freedom of
it under the table you can play a dice
game you can snort a line of coke you
can give it to a stripper you can you
can break the rules we're on the grid
but the illusion of being somewhat Off
the Grid with cash is kind of fun it's
nice and we're gonna talk when it goes
away we're gonna be like man we had some
good times but you could do that with
with uh crypto yeah it's invisible
well
I like to hold it I want to slap it on
my hand and give it to a hooker gotcha
were you into hookers when you were
single no I've actually never I [__]
one but she didn't charge me she's good
oh yeah sure she loved the therapist
I hope not too much no I love are you
sexually attracted to her no come on on
what is she on the couch oh no
um no I'm not sexually attracted I just
love I love therapy
hmm I love therapy I like it too I love
asking questions I let people asking me
questions yeah I like finding patterns
and things that I couldn't see before I
like learning intention also like in
trauma moments like I like somebody to
talk to to like help help me self-soothe
when I can't get there here I'm a big
therapy man same I like it but I feel
like you get the tools you learn what
they they tell you what's what they not
only to go back so I uh like I don't go
every week all the time I'll take months
off yeah and then I'll go back every now
and then for a little and then there's
some times where I notice something that
like I need to work on and I'm like hey
like ask like collaborating with
somebody like hey I'm gonna come in and
then I'll go in once twice a week for a
couple months kind of like loading on a
new supplement or something yeah I think
it bothers them when you turn them into
a part-time gig a little bit yeah they
don't I'll let you speak for my
therapist go on yeah I will I'll speak
for it I don't give a [__] about your
third what about people that go to
comedy shows sometimes when they stop
and they go again it's not a weekly
thing I think they expect you to go
I'm I do it too I'm saying I think I
don't think they like it yeah they don't
like it when I do it either you think
because it affects their product or
they're not making the money they want
probably I think they're both like I'm
not a [__] mechanic this is not a
tune-up but but it is I agree I agree
I'm I'm saying I agree with you when
your car's in a lot of distress you go a
lot more and then when it isn't you
still go get your oil fixed uh change
I'm sorry change changed you get your
oil changed I just [__] you can't say
anything anymore right yeah get your oil
changed or whatever yeah but sometimes I
disagree yeah I'm with you I mean if
they want us to come more then they
should start [__] our lives up yeah
you know you're gonna have to go behind
the scenes they want me to come with I
gotta keep talking about my mom yeah
there we go count it I don't remember
this you have Mom issues I know he has
parent issues you don't have Mom issues
I didn't know everyone has mom issues
mom issues I have is the fact that I we
don't live in the same state so we can't
just laugh and talk all the time in
person
no no we're close it's not bad but it's
like there's still issues
go on
um tell me more how's that make you feel
she raped me
you know what yeah I see it now yeah not
that she raped you but you couldn't even
give one example
we were being sincere for a while and
you you much like what you would advise
you go you heightened too quickly so
there's nowhere to go that's your
version of shutting it down you think I
hiding too quickly oh buddy if you had a
nickname it's heightened too fast yeah
and I'm not talking about your stand-up
curated I'm talking about when you came
on I remember when we were improvising
and like really doing it for real we
would be trying to have a real scene and
we were and we established something and
then you just go and then I raped her
I'm like Sam
he's got a point you notice this you're
a heightener you're a heightener hey
well I'm short I'm a shortener you're
also a heightener Mark what's going on
what what have you learned as an adult
that you didn't know as a kid with your
relationship with your mom
I think there were some tendencies that
uh that she uh could be judgmental and
overbearing in ways and that translated
towards she's a very loving mother yeah
and of course he would say you feel like
you have to qualify this before even
critiquing her but you know obviously
you love and respect your mom and of
course yeah and a distant father throw
that in there well biological father was
yes and yeah my dad was good yeah
um you're close with your with your
stepdad yeah yeah
uh and your mom judged you
I don't think me I think other people I
think like women in my life like I know
my mom I've got some texts from Mom from
your mom that we're pretty judgy how
about you it's like hey when he does
this I hate this yeah no she'll she'll
spread it around no she agreed with this
assessment
I think there's a part of her like she
definitely respects my stand-up and
respects that I built a career of this
but I think I think she wishes I was a
humorist
ah I think she wishes that was like a
New Yorker shouts and murmurs type of
comedian rather than
because I think it's like classier and
like an English muffin I like an English
muffin thank you well you're very well
read you're cultured are you have you
read say Cheese and Die I haven't oh
it's a great Goosebumps damn oh I
actually I might have read that back in
the day how about Cameron Campo which is
the uh Camp one yeah there's a camera
right I don't know was in the camera or
something no Jews love cam no that must
be the same Cheese and Die one nightmare
right I remember this like that's a
concentration camp hello
yeah that would be a weird R.L Stine
departure well it's just just a [__]
Holocaust
um yeah well we're getting somewhere
keep going there Dr glassy
um what were you talking about
Goosebumps for why did that even come up
said she looked like a
Goosebumps
she she likes uh I think she that's more
her Avenue but yeah but she does I mean
she laughs at the show but I've
definitely seen her in the crowd before
where she'll do one of these I go into
like a a joke she doesn't like as much I
see one of these
uh and I'm like you sat too close to the
stage so I can still see you doing that
yeah before I started stand up I went I
I went to I feel like I talked about
this on a podcast once and if it was
this one because I don't know why but
anyway I'm feeling insecure about
repeating something on your pod but lay
it on me uh I went to the Las Vegas
Comedy Festival uh my uncle does
lighting and stuff so like he got me in
and I wasn't even doing stand-up yet but
I got to be in the green room and wow
stuff was very exciting and I went I saw
Seinfeld and Chris Rock and uh I went to
the Chris Rock
um uh uh sound check in the Coliseum at
Caesars and there wasn't very many
people in there and he was up on stage
and he goes uh make sure my mom sits uh
and he said like at a certain row and at
the time I even got it I wasn't even
doing it because he didn't want to see
her reactions to things maybe she reacts
good I don't know but you just don't you
know you don't want to see your mom yeah
but just it's always levels when they
see someone you know
like I'm not gonna Force crowd work but
I might want to do crowd work 45 minutes
into the set sure and then it's like
you're doing crowd we're like what are
you doing like oh that's that's Rob yeah
it's a friend of mine oh that's the word
you feel like you're phony a little bit
because you're performing a little so
you feel they they know what you're
doing the whole thing sucks yeah so what
do you think your mama your mom judging
you has to do with you because you
you're you're you both are but just
speaking for you you're I'm gonna lean
into this type of guy you lean into the
thing and that could be like you know
like pushing back and you know like
being competitive and do you feel like
when some an audience member is heckling
you and or you're on a premise that
people aren't yet on board we're like
hey [__] you and this leaning in thing
is that because they're judging you no I
think that's because if I do a joke
that's kind of like a lean in type of
joke you can't you can't do like a a
half c abortion joke you can't you can't
do like a what abortion joke yeah I'm on
the fence you have to go you have to
lean into whatever the premise is right
or or the joke isn't funny I mean like
same with a comic like look at a comic
like Anthony jeselnick if he took any of
the students like a goose and see what
happens if you took any of the sting out
of his punch lines it just wouldn't be
as funny if there's any lack of
certainty it wouldn't be as funny well
it's well known that his mother judged
him images he is German
ah there's a little Goose going on here
by the way I don't think so I'm just
kidding what a handsome man oh he's a
handsome guy yeah maybe yeah there you
go how about you do you do you uh what
made you be a comedian
the the molesting yeah what's funny
about that well I'm heightening
um should have done that to the camp
counselor not big uh well that's an RL
Stein story if I'm not mistaken that's
true came nowhere yes yes uh I used to
uh uh I have a lot of thinking Master
Vader all right sorry keep going
um
yeah
I would uh
tell jokes
to um be able to slow the sound down
what are we doing here come on
I'm tapping into something that felt
real what is this inside the actor
Studio out with it yeah PBS over here
hit it
um I don't know if you really want me to
yeah yeah
yeah well then maybe give me a little
bit all right sorry sorry you can do it
when I was little yeah
um I was it didn't have
um
feeling in your legs
never mind all right well the pod's over
come on get it out of there hairy arms
what are you what are you playing
Incredible Hulk sad walk away
damn we don't need salad you said oh
Peter's is already killing him Bill
Bixby over here what good pull and um
I had a hard time
yeah with what
fitting in and having my brother was
popular and yeah a lot of friends and
[Music]
I always just felt out of place you know
sure
and um
that must have been very hard for you
Rick
with your tall I wasn't oh
could I use some Heights I wasn't tall
yet oh yeah
I was smart
I was in a science and nerdy [__]
[Music]
I got hit by a gamma ray oh no or as you
would say again but gay because that's
your brand
wow
and I
push it
I
was a boy
I was young
I felt a fool
there should be some one there to hold
my hand in trust that was love
[Music]
and then uh yeah then I got Bobby Lee on
the Pod and realized hey maybe there's
something to these jokes after all you
know he brought a good amount of
audience to the to my podcast and then I
you know started getting in there with
Comics yeah Comics saved the day because
for me to fit I was much like yourself
didn't fit in weirdo but you start
finding booze and that it was a nice
lubricant you mean like like bombing and
people booing you yeah no no that came
later I'm talking about high school yeah
yeah you find booze was a nice uh social
lube and then you meet some weirdo
friends and then you're often cooking
you're both drunks yeah yeah
I would say yes yeah well you did yeah
I'm gonna say it again what if you had
to stop drinking today
where does your happiness and where does
your career go a year from now probably
better off in the long run but that few
first couple of months would be you
think it's just a couple months yeah I'd
have the DTs what if your wife said if
you stop drinking she'll go on an
Elimination Diet what does that mean
she'll figure out Elimination Diet you
figure out you get off all the things
that people are commonly intolerant to
uh like night shades and this is the
most Jewish fantasy about a guy's wife
oh yeah hey uh yeah does your girl she
forgot an illumination diet I don't even
know it sounds like genocide and then
you come back in uh and then you
reintroduce new foods and you find out
what is upsetting you oh she did that
and and she still well [__] like a Jew
if I know women they'll find something
to be upset about
these women all right all right yeah
yeah she did one of those tests at the
hospital and they said you can't have
soy yeah but that's that's that's not
real that's oh really no you gotta
actually do it like I feel like going
and getting blood this is a great
analogy you have to trust me I'm
listening getting blood work to figure
out what your intolerant and allergic to
is like all right all right oh [__] I
forgot I had a great one hold on I know
you finally got that energy up oh
oh yes he's coming dude oh yes yes
[Laughter]
thank God your pants are white
okay oh I forgot what it was it was such
a [__] good one dude wait wait so the
diet don't have soy don't have gluten
she got went to the hospital tell me
about coming in your pants yeah you came
everywhere well anyway when they get the
test and it tells you about some stuff
yeah it's like that's the that you gotta
really do it you got to get off the food
yeah well she's doing that now but she's
going off the list from the hospital
and she feels better yeah and uh
inflammation went down oh yeah she was
huge really that was it was a problem we
were gonna do an Interventional but she
she slimmed down just in the nick of
time yeah it was getting scary we were
worried the divorce paper is ready at a
lawyer on on the line we were concerned
what was your lawyer's name uh fat get
rid of her nice yes have you met
somewhere well Harvey Specter is I'm a
is unbelievable oh okay yeah related to
Phil uh
pull up Harvey Specter
uh you guys might know him he's he's
really good
hmm
oh yes oh that guy's good yeah yeah yeah
he was banging Markle for a hot minute
no you're thinking of Mike Ross I see
stop living on coffee and energy drinks
over half the human body is made up of
water so you should probably drink more
of it liquid IV has you covered it's the
number one powdered hydration brand in
America one stick of liquid IV is 16
ounces of water and it hydrates you
sorry one stick of liquid IV and 16
ounces of water hydrates you two times
faster and more efficiently than water
alone with three times the electrolytes
of leading sports drinks eight vitamins
nutrients and now a sugar-free option
you can't go wrong I use this it helps
with a good hangover or it's uh good
flavors too we got strawberry lemonade
tropical punch Seaberry is one for every
mood definitely big fan just keep it at
the house yeah real people real flavor
real hydration now sugar-free that's my
fave grab your liquid IV hydration
multiplier sugar-free in bulk nationwide
at Costco or 20 off when you go to
liquid iv.com and use code drunk at
checkout that's 20 off anything you
order when you use promo code drunk at
liquid IV dot com
[Music]
here here all right folks we're doing it
we might be drunk as brought to you by
doer stop deciding between comfortable
stylish pants get the pants that look
great and feel great from doer I love
these pants I got some cool shorts they
sent me a long pair and they're [__]
comfortable they're nice they fit
perfectly I wear them like all the time
they're great great jeans I'll send more
if you guys please I would love a darker
pair as well I'm walking rocking that
light blue oh yeah I got the gray and
that that stains easy I look like uh
Lewinsky out here but uh yeah they're
great on a plane they're just so
comfortable love the doer and we run
around town all over all over the place
so we need a nice cool fit to look good
and feel good style your doors up or
down whatever whatever the fit is doers
denim is five times the stretch of
traditional rigid Denim and are designed
to keep you cool dry and any temp and
antibacterial for easy care and less
washing my girl must be wearing them
she's very dry
made for materials like wood chips
plants and recycled bottles wow doer has
finally made sustainable clothing that's
long lasting and stylish trust me you
haven't felt Comfort until you put on a
pair of doers check out doers Flagship
stores in La Denver or get them online
shopdoer.com and our listeners get 15
off site wide using Code drunk for 15
off your order at
sh-o-p-d-u-r-e.com use promo code drunk
and save
shopdoor.com promo code Trump dude you
misspelled it I think oh did i s h o p
d-u-e-r oh you're right
s-h-o-p-d-u-e-r.com
boy she's kind of on the outs oh yeah
why would you say that I feel like she
was hot news for a minute she was on
Oprah she had a Netflix special she's uh
the cut all the victim status from being
half black with the queen and now
everybody hates her
man it's it's tough being Royal yeah
blush yeah do you guys know that song
where it goes
yeah and she said it best man yeah she's
[__] good dude queen bee she's
[__] so we're all we're all [__]
comics in our mid to late 20s who are in
relationships right yeah yeah bro yeah
you hear that right it's not easy being
a boy get my [__] burps dude I'm I'm
tearing this [__] up oh yeah I'm going
crazy today dude if you could have
anybody's voice literal voice yeah whose
would you pick and what would you do
with it RFK Jr no
um
R Kelly but I'd also want to say what he
was feeling
let me we'll put this through a modifier
to make it sound like a tune all right
what does he feel I didn't know this is
going to go any further yeah you got a
heighten [__] dude we're not your mom
[__] you dude you are my mom yeah cause
we're [__] you man [__] you you see the
audience as your mom that serviced you
for a while because you learned what are
you service to me why don't you put your
[__] mouth I'm not even joking pull
your pants down I'm not joking I'll suck
your dick right here prove it witness
pull your pants down unless you're
to
to chicken oh
[Applause]
I can right over here
[__] don't lay an egg
your mommy doesn't want to suck your
dick oh what the [__] dude jeez that was
a little over the line that was [__]
up
you don't think my mom wants to suck my
dick what does that bring up rejection
how so that you know you want like I
don't it's like a wedding invite I don't
want her to suck my dick but I want the
option good point but how would it make
you feel to know that your mom would
judge you if you wanted her to suck your
dick
you don't want a mom job
maybe I do
[Music]
maybe I want my mom to suck me off dude
it's not the first time your dick's been
in her because she made you in her
stomach yeah
yeah that's [__] deep dude
is that weird your mom made your dick
yeah that's a mind twister she's the
oven that made this English muffin yeah
good merch yeah huh good merch yeah oh
your mom's the oven that made this
English muffin it's kind of long for a
t-shirt no she's doing larger bigger
all right
well okay this was fun well
[Laughter]
dude this is gone eight different ways
yeah I love them you can make this
patreon only if you want no I think this
is good stuff there's something here if
the audience could stay with it this up
here I challenge you you guys you you
take you you you take all right all
right well it's good to see you I'll
answer some questions or you could ask
me like questions about like like uh you
know whatever you do and then I'll like
listen to what you guys have to say all
right
you like this lizzo stuff
yeah I'm not I'm not uh I don't care
yeah I don't care either I care a little
I mean I care about so little I know and
that's what's an interesting thing when
we're in a business about having strong
points of view yeah in order to be
authentic I'm being sincere in order to
be authentic to find things that you
actually care about yeah it's true you
know it's it's not the deepest well and
to tell jokes or to write stuff about
things that you care about no but that
you don't care but just because like you
know we do this all the time right and
to come up with things or to talk on
about like uh no but you think you have
to care about the thing to write a joke
about it
if I I think that I think that to write
jokes about stuff I don't care about is
so draining and I start to I I felt
myself resenting
doing this is that why all your jokes
about uh raping children he's just
joking
that's what you hear about I don't I
don't care about so they don't care
about them but I care about them but I'm
not doing anything to stop it true I
mean if I saw it happening I was walking
around last time I was visiting here I
was in the city and there was two kids
I'm making this age up a give or take
two years between 10 and 12. okay and
they were playing by the uh the whatever
that happened you know around zero
What's the tower called now Freedom
Tower freedom and there's like a
fountain by there and they were playing
in there with like the water and stuff
and they were running around and they
were black and there was a Oh this is
getting more no and they were black and
there was an older white man who was
taking videos of them yeah and they
never acknowledged each other and Evan
Spacey was there dude all right bro dude
bro and uh I we I waited and I didn't
want to go up and say something because
just because there's black kids in a a
white old person doesn't mean that
they're not you know what did Maya
Angelou say black kids and white older
people go hand in hand yeah they make
you feel right um but I was watching to
make sure for a little bit because like
is this inappropriate but like oh no
they I realized they were together
because they had something in his bag
but I'm saying like if there's something
that's happening inappropriate I'll I'll
I'll try and do what I can would you
have fought that guy
I I wasn't thinking I had fought but I
did have enough adrenaline and like I'm
ready to go up and say what's going on
here well absolutely yeah what have you
said just [__] I'll be the old man
you be two little kids running around
playing water and you be the you be you
and I'll be the old man and I'm just
watching okay but but hold on I have a
question for you it doesn't matter yet
yeah I'm black oh wait yeah yeah we're
playing the water okay yeah
that'll do just fine yeah that's this
stuff right there yeah I'm black oh
spank bang for later for sure excuse me
excuse me I'm in the middle of something
are you is this is is this your friend
or person that's my dad oh this is your
dad yeah absolutely pardon me I was just
looking because it felt a little
inappropriate because you were saying oh
yeah I like that okay how I how do I
[__] my kids it's none of your business
yeah we like it
shame on you yeah shame on you
9-1-1 oh we got you there dad oh man you
think they can stop me I donate so much
money that Precinct I donate to the
[__] ball and I'm happy to help too
but they're not gonna do [__] to me they
know this happens that's how corrupt the
[__] NYPD is are you all right with
this I love it so well that's why I'm in
the fountain I gotta clean up yeah
[Applause]
all right thank you for your concern
yeah please leave us alone absolutely
I'm going to take them back and that
would be about the extent yeah yeah well
Jokes Aside jokes aside I I when you see
stuff sometimes like like uh if you see
something say something yeah and I I I I
have what's going on here you've done
that yeah not oh not always like kid
stuff but if there's something that's
inappropriate I remember once it's it's
I mean the stakes are so much lower but
I hate smoking that's I know it's an
opinion weed or cigarettes or what well
wait I see you do have opinions I have
opinions but I'm saying if it's stuff
that I don't this is something I do care
about there you go but that's all they
don't care about like the lizzo [__] no
I was just I was just [__] around but
yeah smoking cigarettes it's I mean dude
it's not 98 stop right but if you're
gonna do it do your thing but not by me
like I'll be even with friends and if
we're walking we're smoking cigarette
I'll say hey I'll either go on the other
side or ask them to switch hands and
blow it away or I'll just go get the
it's gross it smells I hate it yeah
being said
that's your thing go do it but there are
certain boundaries that I feel are
should be Universal and I remember at
The Comedy Store there was a guy that
was smoking and he was walking in and he
took a hit right before he walked up the
steps into the original room and he just
threw the cigarette on the ground on the
on the floor on the ground Legend and I
uh
I went up to him I said excuse me uh oh
God I said I think you I think you
dropped your cigarette like a little
Pastor aggressive getting the benefit of
the doubt for him to be like oh sorry
yeah no I meant to I was done with it I
go oh the garbage is right there oh
and I'll tell you something in the
moment I didn't feel
the adrenaline and confrontational but
as soon as I said the garbage was right
there which I was being sincere I was
like hey man it's right there
I I got this adrenaline rush and I'll
tell you something I liked it and then
right after that Andrew Dice Clay beat
the [__] out of here no he said sorry
and he picked up he threw it away really
he did yeah but I wasn't going up to him
being an [__] and being like hey [__]
you or like at least my intention at the
time wasn't like was he a big guy he was
a he was definitely he definitely was
bigger than me wow because you're pretty
tall I don't I don't I could be wrong
but I wasn't worried about thinking like
this guy's gonna punch me now I also
felt like
he definitely hated you he threw the
cigarette away I know but he's cursing
you in his headline you should have kept
it going you should now kiss me yeah I'm
kissing me dude see how far I can get
when I see people doing stuff that feels
objectively wrong yeah I
I don't I like getting into it really
really how many how many white
supremacist marches have you stopped but
that's the thing I'm not like going out
of my way it's not like this big moral
thing where I'm like I am you know
Batman standing up for the people that
need to and I'll be the bad guy yeah
just if I see something it's like what
the [__] are you I was on the plane and
somebody farted it happens but for 45
minutes every like five or so it
happened probably eight times yeah and
I'm at a certain point I'm like what the
[__] and I know I handled that wrong I I
know I handled wrong but I said oh what
the [__] yeah and the flight attendant
came over and knew what I was talking
about and brought spray because I'm so
sorry
once this person leaves I'll go in the
bathroom I go it's not from the bathroom
it's one of these people
this is like a Knives Out movie right
here
um great but like what are you doing so
like the the the motivation you ever
doing something and you're excited and
then you lose motivation part of the
craft is well you keep doing the joke
anyway or you keep writing the thing
anyway but like that's part of the
process I don't feel that way with like
this kind of [__] once I'm no longer
invested I'm out but in a moment when
stop stop doing that yeah well the
problem with the farting is you'll never
get the culprit
what are you gonna sniff everybody's
crotch you could I guess it was this
person and the person in front of you
knew it I'll tell you how I knew that
because when I because I
I can't be positive but it but it was
happening it was so strong and on planes
like it doesn't smell as much a few
seats back which you can see this have
you noticed before sure yeah it was one
of these things and there was a lot of
space between us and when I said and I
and I looked over these people the other
person they could have been a great
actor but the other person was just
going oh
and this person didn't acknowledge it
and they heard it oh also big guy
just a regular looking Dad okay okay Dad
fart is a doozy and the dad was holding
a child who I don't again I'm not good
with ages but we'll say give or take a
year three 38. and there's some
turbulence and the kid I didn't see but
from the thing uh fell on the ground the
dad of the kid the kid fell on the
ground Jesus the kid was crying a little
and picked him up how how old is this
kid three maybe three I mean a toddler I
think three two and then picked up the
kid and then was like looking around and
in turn we're like this hit the kids hit
hit the head of the thing and I'm
already thinking like
this this this guy this is the farter
is unaware and inconsistent he doesn't
care
now that's his own Kitty would do that
too what would he do to you I'll tell
you what he would do shut the [__] down
take some IB guard because it was stinky
yeah and when I get it when adrenaline
goes up I'm I'm into like I feel this
way in the podcast sometimes I've had
some episodes where it gets a little
confrontational yeah because and it's
like
great
go on what would you do if the guy talks
[__] back to you
wait with that scene where Mark is my
kid maybe maybe he's not my kid in the
scene let's let's try it one more time
let's see what you would actually do
here all right can I ask a favor of you
sure because I want to play this real
could you not heighten this quickly of
course to be like oh I rape my son it's
like all right well then what the [__]
okay I made a choice and the fact that
you can't accept that choice I'm not
your mom dude oh what the [__] dude what
the [__] all right he's not the farter
play the music okay
back off Mom thank you back off all
right
uh oh pulling out the knife cannot be
your mother
but I am your biological father dada and
the reason I left your mother
speak
it was because I felt judged
[Music]
and I'm sorry that by leaving her
I left you
I think about it every day I do this he
doesn't have a mustache
you just carry a mustache
that was great the fact he'd been
walking around New York City with that
in your pocket what if I need to buy a
fake ID yeah good point all right go
ahead do it all right so now you need to
be a certain age to buy the cake based
on no other nevermind no I'm making
myself look older so because people who
sell fake IDs they want to make sure
you're still of age really I thought
there's a whole point of the fake ID
unless you're a migrant
yeah I was just I see sorry continue
uh all right so wait the farting guy
really got it yeah just one more time
one more time even you're rolling your
eyes yeah
one more time Mark is now in this scene
Mark uh as the black I'm playing the
black shot okay it's not I was built to
play it's not my son are you ready yeah
was it son it was a boy and a girl
there's two kids okay but you were
playing both the black boy and the black
girl black kid okay you ready
yeah oh yeah that's a good one
I'm all wet oh yeah excuse me sir what's
going wait uh is this I'm so sorry I see
you're filming something are you guys
together I'm a photographer and are you
I'm a little black kid
I'm just taking do you have a problem
with photography I'm trying to do you
know them
do you have you seen a photographer they
take pictures of things on the street
without asking do I know a building back
there without their parents permission
I'm I'm gonna uh you gotta stop doing
that man oh um
no I'm not I'm gonna get you now oh
because you don't support the Arts and
you won't let me pursue my passion with
the photography oh [__] you don't know
me yeah I'll get out of here that's
really [__] up dude back off back yep
officer
this man won't let me photograph these
black kids
hey New York's finest baby wow I got you
good you didn't know what to do what's
the Lord Michaels yeah you didn't know
what to do you guys ever audition for
SNL no no yeah when you were first
starting out did you ever did was that a
thing that you thought you wanted to do
I would have taken anything yeah no I
was like I was I would have loved to do
Weekend Update at some point but that's
the only thing your mom would like that
oh wow
I would like you would like that because
you get to sit in a suit you get this
you get swirled Scotch do you think your
mom would like you better if you wore a
suit on stage
I'm still doing the same material but
that would probably class it up yeah I
don't know I think the suit look can
look really cool I mean I'm producing
Gary veter special and I got him a sick
suit oh you went mom on him I went mom
on him I was like because he does all
one liner so I thought it would be a
cool look for like a one-liner comic
he's kind of no you should do it should
be tight on him the whole the whole
thing but then the last 15 minutes you
reveal wide that he's just naked
yeah you could call you could call it
Gary Vader uh raw and uncensored there
you go Bears all yeah I can't find the
picture I'll find it later I've seen it
he looks great in a suit he looks cute
little yeah there is suit confidence
I've I've gone on stage in a suit a few
times and I was I was wearing a suit for
something and then I had a show yeah and
there is something about suit confidence
where like
if it weren't for me not wanting to wear
a suit all the time I would do it yeah
it's annoying dry cleaning and all that
stuff like you wear this how many suits
do you want me to have yeah right but
like there is something that they cast
the audience casts you as something that
I feel is very beneficial where you
could lean into the classy or you could
be you know like the antithesis of it
but either way it serves a purpose yeah
like Stanhope will wear like funny
Blazers and stuff you know oh yeah he's
got the Zoot Suit it's a weird orange
and patterns we should start wearing
suits on stage yeah just and you don't
have to think about your outfit you just
pick the suit up put it on it looks good
women I think really like women love a
suit is that true yeah they did a poll
and I said the way women feel about like
a nice tailored suit is how men feel
about lingerie
yeah dude you put that suit on all the
[__] it's gonna be wet at the Rick
Glassman show bro I have to say and I'm
in a relationship and I'm not even
looking toward this end I'm not even the
funniest person in the um funniest one
of the it doesn't matter I have found
that a lot of uh and they tell me like
girls usually like they do get
wet during my shows oh really yeah what
do you put a towel down on all the seats
or how does that work
no it's just
I have this bit I came up with where
um I smash a watermelon
that's good stuff never heard of that
yeah hmm
you guys Gallagher fans he had some good
word play I was never I never got into
it he doesn't he got he got a bad rap
with the Sledge of magic and the hair
and the hat and the whole thing but his
word play is pretty great
I mean if there's a clip went viral like
a week ago it already has like 20 000 or
20 million views and uh it's clever as
[__] I mean I don't know if it's your
cup of jizz but it is clever I just
remember before I was into comedy on a
new comedians like as a kid I knew
Gallagher right we all did and I
remember I used to think I used to think
it was really funny but I couldn't I
can't think of one the ball with the
long hair is such a bad look it's a bad
wrestling Eve used to have a great joke
you ever see a bald guy with a ponytail
it looks like all his hair got together
and hung itself
[Laughter]
well I don't know if you're gonna find
the exact clip It's All Over YouTube but
some some dweeb posted it and it just
went viral immediately because it it
still holds up and I'm not saying it's
the funniest [__] ever it's not n-words
versus black people but uh who's the
funniest comedian ever I don't Rodney
maybe I don't know Dangerfield's hard to
beat for me it just you can't he walks
in the room and you're ready yeah that's
even easy money when he when he's
singing felikili follicula It's just
insane it's like he's just singing but
it's funny like a movie with a an
unbelievable Rodney impersonator oh
really unbelievable sound like him knew
all of his jokes and it just crushed
well he was just crushing yeah great
jokes yeah yeah you're right he walks in
the room it's funny because he's a fat
ugly guy who's confident and extremely
happy and that combination is is he ugly
what are you kidding he's a ghoul look
at the photo look at that he's a wacky
looking guy I mean Rodney Dangerfield
good looking picture look at that it
just looks like a guy to me well he's no
Adonis he looks like a comedian good
looking
I mean even there he looks like hell
he's a gargoyle I'll tell you it was
ugly my mother never breastfed me she
told me she liked me as a friend how
does that make you feel bad makes me
feel [__] Rodney in therapy
you can't he can't crack how does it
make me feel he should have seen me last
week
I asked for a second opinion he said hey
you're ugly too if you had to do an SNL
audition and do Impressions what would
be your three Impressions
I don't do impressions
who would you do uh I had I did submit
one and if you want I could send it to
you to put it in I did one where I did
um Jada pink and Smith
uh what do you do hey go slap him
um we'll cut to a clip it was before
that stuff this is like
12 years ago
I did um
uh
uh Denzel Washington
when I get finished with y'all you've
been playing basketball
23 hour locked out I'm the Man opened
this piece you've never seen a lot who
the [__] do you think you messing with
I'm the police up here you'll just live
here
[__] on me
hmm
um I did uh I don't like to get wet
though uh Primo angel dust PCP Training
Day yeah I did a different training day
oh okay okay wow
okay there we go
Roman
The Big Three yeah yeah exactly
do you do a good Denzel
um I don't I used to I practice a lot
well well would you I'll send it you
we'll put a put a moment of it in type
it in yeah all right wow that's a that's
a clay like James Adomian he did like
great impressions of really kind of
obscure people yeah although those
aren't too obscure but pink it it was
good all right the Jada Pinkett was good
um I'd have to see it did you think when
if you were to make it on here were you
planning on going blackface for the
thing I didn't put out Blackfoot you
don't have to do blackface
you don't have to put on a suit I know
but isn't it weird but it's just a white
guy to come out and do Jada Pinkett yeah
I mean they didn't book me did you shave
your head
no okay so it's just you but you're
doing her voice
kinda but in touch with Jada Pinkett
Smith one now imagine if you've gotten
hired and then the Will Smith thing
happened they'd be like thank God we
hired this guy we could pull him out of
the closet and let him do this one thing
he does everyone at home watches like
that's not Jada Smith right right yeah
but you don't have to make them believe
you are that it just has to be enough of
a thing I don't believe that reality and
then
you get to like live in that ironic
space right but usually on SNL they look
like the person throw the costume you
put a wig on me okay all right now we're
getting somewhere yeah you could put a
wig on me yeah there's the glasses yeah
okay
oh now I see oh yeah kind of a goose
yeah all right what about you what would
your impressions be well I just learned
I could do RFK
that's one that's good thank you I could
do Donald Duck wow
you can do an elephant
where do I sign
all right good stuff all right
a couple animals there's no animals on
the on the cast I've noticed so
somebody's got to do it
how about an owl
all right these sketches are gonna write
themselves yeah this is good you were a
bird on mine once that was a bird yeah
oh wait what was that I don't remember
but you know he made me into a bird on
your animation yeah you said you wanted
to do I want to be a pigeon no it was a
pigeon we're talking about what animal I
would be one time Whitney said I should
there should be like an animated show
where I voice a pigeon oh that's pretty
good yeah she's like you should be like
a pigeon talking about living in the
city yeah New York pigeon yeah I like
that what animal would you maybe what a
ferret
let's throw some some Warby Parkers on a
ferret and we got it come on that felt
anti-semitic no no no that would be more
of a rat I guess they're both rodents
um hold on what would you be maybe an
otter
yes gay with little hair
that's what gays call you're an otter in
the gay World an anteater you know those
restaurants where they're like they're
mean to you yes I love this
you know it'll be fun is to is to uh
three of us to be waiters at that
restaurant you film it you know hidden
camera style and uh see if because those
people they do jokes and they I don't
know how good they are how funny they
are but like for us to like go as hard
as possible it's personality driven
there's more sass there's a burger place
called Paul's and there's a waitress
who's kind of like that I remember but
that's it's supposed to be that yeah no
it's not but she's just kind of sassy
but it works it's fun but yeah I think
this is the one where they're like
they're like uh they come to your table
and like they drop it down like hurry up
and order they're like me yeah but I'd
love to do that where it's like uh hey
you know here order something for me hey
I'm gonna get the milkshake and the
cheeseburger okay
[Laughter]
boy [__] you didn't you didn't take my
order
oh I'm sorry am I your mommy
oh doggy there you go now he's coming if
this was six years ago I would have I
would have uh for the joke I know I
would have really like hit and pushed
and done stuff because I thought you
guys would have thought it was funny
yeah and uh I'm really proud of myself
for not really doing anything too
aggressive there you didn't know yeah
good for you good stuff we've gotten
we've grown up I used to want to wrestle
uh when kids would come over when I was
younger
not too far yeah they stopped coming
over yeah was that kid you paralyzed the
kid no but I would I would talk about it
I talk about the kid you killed I did
not make a kid pass out in my basement
really we were wrestling I put him in a
choke hold uh and you made him benefits
so scary because I know that was a thing
he just fell oh it's okay he just passed
out and I was scared and he woke up I
don't remember like 20 seconds or 10
seconds later or something two years
later and he was like
mommy yeah now that kid's in therapy
yeah yeah maybe but he was a really fast
dribbler I remember yeah you go real low
and dribble real he was dribbling when
you had choked him yeah but why do you
choke him out just you I thought we were
we were wrestling and like that's what
you do and and like I you just were
wrestling and I would and we also went
my brother really like he got boxing
gloves and and uh they're boxing the
basement and like his older friends and
they some of them like to do it but when
I was boxed I used to love it really
that was fun yeah
um we did wrestling no we didn't box
um yeah and then then like uh lightsaber
fights where I would ask them to court
like I want to choreograph a fight and
like I don't want to and I was like no
no trust me you'll have a good time yeah
all right and then they didn't come over
again oh damn [__] you're up that'll
[__] up your childhood but it sounds
like you got a little rage in you there
fatty no it it felt like uh it's what I
love about basketball so much I think we
talked about this once we're like I love
being aggressive and playing that way
like it doesn't feel like anger it feels
like connection to me oh interesting
like talking [__] you know like when you
talk [__] with somebody like and you go
harder and harder some people might be
like [__] you and like getting triggered
or it's just like it's a competitive
it's just I've always loved being
physical and like I just love it but you
were you take it too far sometimes yeah
I took it too far a fair amount of times
and you yelled the guy on the airplane
with the baby
I didn't yell at him I just said what
the f what uh what the [__]
that's so funny so bad I nearly took it
I nearly I went after a woman behind me
it's air Justice I look at it it's just
it I think what a movie I think civil
you have to be civilized when you're
around other people it's such a peep of
mine as
you know enclosed spaces and someone
acts like it's their [__] home yeah
it's it's unacceptable uh I would like
you to have merch called air Justice and
it's a silhouette of you like this but
your posture is a little you know like
this and you have your hair on it
instead of the bald head yeah I like it
that's not a joke on your posture it was
more of a Jewish overall thing I see
whatever it is what if the person on the
plane behind you do that made you she
was gabbing like it was you know she
this happens a lot of people get drunk
on a I don't know I think I told the
story on the plot I'll tell a short
version uh people they act like it's
their home she was apparently uh I mean
she was going loud like ah like scream
laughing right behind my eyes I'm like
watching something no she's talking to a
guy who I thought they were like
flirting hit it off but turns out he was
probably annoyed as [__] oh I'm sure she
was like kind of a hot older woman stage
Mom it turns out which shock her how it
turns out because I saw you Tweeting
something about it yeah yeah yeah
because some guy behind me I guess knew
who I was and he saw my tweet where I
was like God this [__] human body
what he said I didn't say yeah he wrote
he wrote something like Sam Morrell just
told me to [__] off and I said no I told
the woman I've responded like no I was
telling the woman sitting next to you to
stop talking so loud I was I was like
you know it's pretty reasonable how I
responded I was like miss you got to
keep it down it's good for you yeah
would you be able to do that no no not
in a million years I'd give her one of
these
right and hope that that satisfied now
when you say that are you nervous or you
feel like I needed to and uh everyone
around me was like give me a look like
like oh that's cool we were on a flight
once cross country to uh Seattle as me
Gary veteran and Brian who's my tour
manager and Brian has no fear talking
[__] to people he's we all kind of veter
will do the same thing yeah there's a
woman behind me and she won't she's
pissed drunk she gets cut off by the guy
she's she's just screaming and it's one
of the things where I said it to the I
said it to them and the guy she's
screaming to the point where I'm like
dude shut the [__] up it's insane the
the people in the front were annoyed and
uh he's like missed you've had too much
to drink I'm sorry I can't give you
which by the way that's a sign right
yeah so I turned around and I finally
she's screaming and both me and we're
looking at each other like I can't I
have no he's canceling headphones on I'm
hearing you so I go I go you gotta keep
it down right and the guy gives me a
look like okay but then at the same time
he goes he goes we weren't being loud
and I go you were and then he goes one
of these like I could see him like
bubbling with rage like Furious that I
just told him to keep it down
inconsiderate people have no idea no
idea about what they're doing so then
but some people truly don't know and I
could tell you I have been in as I'm
sure you can imagine a fair amount of
positions where people have said to me
hey shhh yeah and my instinct is usually
like that's what I've been doing me too
but that's that my problem is not just
that it's the then the afterwards
because then she just keeps doing it and
then Gary realizes it's his turn and he
goes lady enough and then
Gary's Gary's another New York guy he'll
[__] do that and then and his feet
are good and then Brian sees that we're
losing it and Brian's on the other side
of her so Brian are you know the
Tormentor Brian Hubbard who I love uh
basically he he gets annoyed with her
she kicks a bottle in this direction
like just no manners and he goes you're
trash lady you're trash and it's going
on now and then of course she pulls the
thing as next door he's sitting next
door he's and they're both aisle so then
he does the uh when when we land finally
after we all [__] lose on the the
flight attendants like I'm so sorry he
hates her too what are you gonna do I
feel bad he's got to deal with her yeah
so then we land she's a thing like do
you guys hate me oh it's like I do it's
like what do you want out of this
interaction yeah what do you think what
do you want from us
she wants you to not hate her yeah play
the play the music
lead him in with you guys hate me
do you guys hate me
I don't hate just you I hate everything
you represent you're an inconsiderate
[__] wow you probably had a horrible
horrible father bad mother too I would
guess yeah you never grew out of it you
never got the attention you seeked
that's why on a flight you're so loud
that everyone around you has to hear the
most mundane thoughts you think are
interesting so you drink yourself into a
stupor nothing I get like less than a
drunk who can't handle their [__] learn
how to drink if you're gonna drink be a
civilized [__] adult don't ruin my
flight and don't make it so I can't
watch the movie Tomcat starring Jerry
O'Connell on this flight
okay well I guess you do hate me then
now I'm gonna kill myself thanks a lot
comedian guy funny man causes death on
Seattle air Justice
coming to CNN this fall I worked on a
peeve I had something he's got a pave
and he peeve and he peeves you guys have
any pieces you know my dad was talking
to me the other day I forgot you guys do
this because
um he he said I got a whole bunch of pet
peeves my dad we podcast together
sometimes and really I was yeah uh uh
and uh a fair amount actually wow and uh
I was talking about they might want to
move and get a place in California and
and uh we're talking about money I'm
like I'll give you my patreon and why
don't you just do and he's like maybe
once and he was like I think maybe I
want to do one where I just talk about
all my pet peeves hey so I don't
remember what they were
um but I'm gonna uh get him on the horn
all right
I met him he's a smooth cool dude owns a
rug store out in Cleveland
if you're looking for just the right
flooring you need choices and at
Marshall Carpet One you'll find
thousands of choices
including carpet
Hardwood
rugs
and luxury vinyl
so make the right choice and visit
Marshall Carpet One in rug gallery
and we promise with more than 50 years
as a family-owned business
we've got you covered
[Music]
I miss you so much already that I'm home
and you're not here I miss you too but
um I was just I was just at home I'm on
a podcast with a with one guy who has no
relationship with his dad and the other
one is I am judges him yeah uh Sam
Morrell and Mark Norman very different
fathers hey Mr glasses
production even with
this guy
hands off dude sorry sorry he's a dilf
um so they end their podcast all the
time with pet peeves and and I know you
have a whole bunch of them
yeah okay well here here's my lady all
right all right here we go guys so
you know when someone is on their phone
or something oh you gotta see this they
want to show your video they want to
show you an Instagram post they want to
show you a text right and again you got
to see this so okay I dropped everything
I'm doing and I'm going over to see it
and it takes them five minutes
that's a great one okay I hate that
great peeve you got another one we like
that I love it I'm gonna go office for a
second I'm going off that for a sec
because I love that I had a guy in the
street
love when someone says you know hey I
love your comedy can I take a pic always
happy to do it Dad could you hear yeah
but this guy is this is a classic thing
they can't figure out their [__]
phone how hard is it I could figure out
your phone yes the guy was like oh you
don't need to unlock it uh what do I do
you've never taken a picture I know I
know do you ever take someone else's
phone to do it for him I've done it yeah
when they take it too I'm like oh give
it to me and I did a selfie yeah the
worse when they gotta flip it around
they're like how do I make it not look
at that thing over there looking at me
and I'm like just push the flip around
button it's right there look at this Dad
we're part of the game now
I know it so here here's another one I
love this and you guys you're in the
city so you don't drive that much okay
but use your [__] turn signal yeah
here here okay well these are great I
think you got a podcast on your hands
there Mr glassy listen guys I I'm moving
to the to Palm Desert next year and I
need something I need supplemental
income in order to do it will you guys
go on my dad's patreon I will yeah I
don't know where Palm Desert is well you
could you'll do it yeah I'll zoom in but
all right Dad you just got yourself some
big guests on your patreon those are big
guests and I'm ready for it thanks dudes
thanks dudes thank you Dad this podcast
all right bye-bye oh is there anything
you want to plug
you got some dates any deals on the
carpets how about here's the title how
about what would chaps the ass of Mr
glass
from HBO oh yeah what's the deal
9.95 a month yeah we must say that's
that's a that's an emir joke that that
uh oh we do all the time oh okay I
thought everybody came up with it right
no Amir oh no that's not an Amir joke
that's um a meerkat that's uh Frazier
Smith and we talked to we told that joke
once with Amir what's the joke uh he
goes uh uh uh I'm really excited guys
things are going well just gotta uh I
just got a new deal for me by with HBO
yeah and they applaud yeah and then you
know that's funny you know 29 whatever
the month of the month yeah that's good
that's good all right is Liam mcanin
used to have a joke well back in the day
where we'd say uh I just signed a deal
with Disney and everyone would clapping
to go that I have to stay uh 500 feet
from their parking lot
nice another another misdirect yeah what
happened to that guy
you got too close to Disney and there
you go it turns out that wasn't a joke
turns out there's no jokes
oh I've seen a few of those they're out
there I gotta I got another piece if you
guys are ready can I can I give another
piece yeah yeah I got a thing happening
and this is summer New York so it'll
happen uh
frequently to conserve they can serve
air conditioning in certain old New York
buildings and they just conserve it so
I'll just wake up covered in sweat like
what the [__] and then they're like I'll
get an email the next day like we had to
conserve air just so it doesn't black
out because these are like old units
right but you're like you know what
conserving it means I don't have air
yeah that means there's no air and I'm
[__] sweating wow in the middle of
the night too and you're not expecting
it that's [__] up although I think
expect in the middle and I do you mark
no that's when they get you
that you know that's the one good thing
is I I felt like I was coming down with
something this weekend and I feel like I
sweated out from there oh it's a good
thing okay that's the thing you're
supposed to do when you're not feeling
well
kids and sweatshops never get sick isn't
that true oh yeah those iPhones to keep
on a pumping and Nikes I don't think
they get sick days that's true too I
don't think they're like you know what
I'm not gonna come in today I think they
probably yeah that's another thing that
like if I were walking around and then I
saw kids forcing being forced to do this
type of work I would like I would need
to do something but I know it's acted
out right now Mark's a kid Mark's a
kid's aren't playing I'll do it because
you're great at the ACT outs aren't
playing they're working buddy all right
so so you what's going on I'm the kid
I'm using my little Chinese okay let's
get my point out before this act up okay
sure what I'm saying is but like knowing
it's happening I'm not I'm still using
iPhone I'm not doing anything so like I
think it's wrong and I would do
something if it was in front of me sure
but like knowing it's happening it's
like I don't like if if I saw lizzo go
up to another dance I don't care about
lizzo oh what I'm saying if I saw it if
I were there and lizzo goes up to
somebody and grabs their tits and be
like dance [__] I'll be like lizzo what
are you doing yeah but now I hear that
it's happening he's like I don't know it
doesn't I'm not in it doesn't concern me
right now you're what we call a
proximity activist yeah it's got to be
right in your vicinity yeah so if you
were alive in the 1940s and you read
about the Holocaust you wouldn't care
okay first of all there's a difference
between not caring and not doing
anything about it okay so you're saying
you wouldn't do anything about the
Holocaust
I I would take I would take people in
but I'm not enlisting
well that would travel that would
require travel yeah proximity yeah I'm
not I'm not you know what I better go
take arms no but like no legs
but if you know if like if the
Underground Railroad was happening
around me and then yeah the subway and
people were like hey have you seen
Patriot which by the way I rewatched the
first I just rewatched it too holy [__]
now he's an anti-semite I could get
behind yeah that is a movie man this guy
[__] likes what women want to that's
a turd of a film right that was our
first argument great our first argument
Nancy Myers what women want is a solid
rom-com well it's a solid rock the
premise is great every guys wanted to
know what a woman's thinking I know what
they're thinking damn what's going on
with that guy yeah look at that Mama
curls but uh uh Patriot when when uh
spoiler alert kind of when when the
something happens to one of his sons
yeah and then they grab the Heath
Ledger's character and they go and he
has to get his other two little boys and
he goes and we don't we don't know who
his character is yet he's a badass yeah
he fought like dirty he fought like with
with axes and in the woods not the
straight up you shoot we shoot yeah and
he just went and they called him The
Ghost and he just have you seen this
movie I haven't seen it bro oh it's I'm
on the plane watching it I've seen it so
many times and I'm out loud I'm going
[__] it's basically John Wick and
Colonial time yes it's it's so good it's
fun to watch it's a dude flick with
history and axes and he's and he has
like his little boys like listen
um you follow your older brother and his
older brother's probably like 13. the
other one's like 10 or so and you know
I'm not great with ages yeah and just
like and then they go in the trees and
they set the Guns and he goes and
they're doing the throne yeah and then
the kids it was just this Dad they don't
know anything about him and then they
see him just like [__] go into town
and there's the blood is coming up and
they're just and then just the shot he's
going nuts and because one of his kids
just spoiler alert got shot and killed
and you never saw this in him and then
you just see all the sons including the
adult one that just like they've never
seen this before and it's just a
Goosebumps right now you just see them
like this RL Stine like they can't
believe what just happened yeah well
this is you and one more fart happens on
a Jet Blue flight you're going full
Gibson on someone's ass with two axes
what I'm saying is like if there's
soldiers coming around here and like
many people need protection there's a
decent chance I'm gonna be at least you
could hide in here yeah but I'm not
taking taking a flight I get it yeah I
was just trying to bait yeah I wouldn't
either well you're a masturbator I'll
tell you that yeah that was a great
Ranch there too and we got a pro Gibson
Jew over here which is rare well Pro
patreon bro what women want and pro
Daddy's home too and propane yeah yeah
if you like uh uh Beavis and Butthead
what's that guy's name Beavis no it's
butthead you know the guy that did uh uh
judge Mike Judge yeah but the king of
the helmet oh Hank Hill um did you guys
see Daddy's home too no is it good what
is this the the thumbs down edition of
Siskel is more [__] movies Daddy's home
have you seen it Daddy's home too no I
didn't see the first one I couldn't
understand the second one if you comment
in here if not only you've seen it
Daddy's home too with Will Ferrell Mark
Wahlberg oh it was uh I'm thinking a
boss baby
no it's legitimately
baby on here oh it's another Gibson John
let's go and Mel Gibson
and the great guy a guy who goes on
adult Pockets you haven't seen boss baby
too are you [__] kidding me yeah
that's actually a fun podcast just
around boss baby and when he goes on
other podcasts that's all he talks about
Kobe Bryant's in this welcome to the
boss Baby cast here guys it's
legitimately very very funny why no one
talking about great cast it's great it's
a great movie look go to hit the Rotten
Tomatoes who's in the first I'm curious
I want the audience score uh Wahlberg
and Will Ferrell okay got it I'm telling
you Kobe Bryant go go down
oh there he is oh yeah go up yeah you're
right Kobe Bryant
what pull up the Rotten Tomatoes I don't
remember any of that Bill Burr's in it
yeah Bill Burr's played a patron in a
movie theater uh what a cast yeah that
sounds great he thumbs down on me just
because you haven't heard of it yet 21
on Rotten Tomatoes yeah a lot of
comedies all right go to the audience
score that's what I want to know
75 75 by the audience that's pretty good
that's a 60 plus 51. hey look at look at
me look at me look at me oh John Cena
I'm telling you this movie is very funny
maybe I'll give it a shot all right
we'll give it a shot tomorrow what do
you think
oh [__] he liked the first one what do
you think be honest if he wasn't here if
I just said before he built it up like
this I was like what do you think of
Daddy's home too what would you say
really Patriot great you know he's never
heard daddy's home
all right do you have a pet peeve you
want to get out or no
this is this has been all right we got a
place
you know what you think where's your
show New York comedy club oh [__] it
takes 10 minutes to get there all right
well I'd like to prepare but yeah oh
there it is we got the trailer
have feathers to cover up his butt quack
oh that's pretty good all right I'm in
that's all I needed I'm sold but uh oh
thank you
collect all five I look pretty cool with
Venom here yeah that's a good pick
nice I got the uh the ABS I got a little
guy on my shoulder who's that guy so I
have I always have a goblin in every
card because that's my uh like my mascot
oh fun so the goblin takes on different
forms okay
um are these so I get one of each yeah
if you want uh if you like these not
many people are collectors I am but if
you are I could I'll be happy to send
you a set they're very they're all very
cool all right all right but uh we just
had the Workaholics they're all uh
Fantastic Four it's awesome
who's the Invisible Woman
um
oh no he's the the thing he was on a
Theo's part it was a great listen yeah I
was listening to a Clipper he said
Marvel movies killed the uh oh yeah
that's great show comedies let me see
the card version oh yeah right there wow
now look at the top one where you see
all of them together well that's pretty
cool aren't those cool very cool I got
Elon Musk in the bottom right that's not
bad does look like Elon Musk oh yeah
um all right boys all right plug some
stuff man you got you guys Oh I thought
we were done oh you got a plug
um just take your shoes off podcast or
my Instagram or glass or whatever you
know great great pod one of the most fun
pods I mean
um that's cool oh Santino looks great I
love that yeah saber tooth and Toad go
to the full the full picture of It Isn't
that cool oh my God
draws these he's a Marvel illustrator
he's [__] incredible wow
uh
oh that's perfect go back uh Vegas dads
click that one that's my dad and my
cousin Teddy and Uncle Bob and stuff
made of Dragon Ball Z guys that's what
your dad does look like wow they
captured it cool right very cool anyway
thanks for having me uh I'm sure you
guys will leave a lot of this in so
thanks to the audience for your patience
for those of you finished we had a lot
of downbeats but I'll tell you something
yeah
I only see you guys when we do this
stuff I would love to see you more hit
me up a pleasure to pleasure doing
business I'll be going to um uh get some
pastrami sandwiches coming to the city
once or twice a week to get a sandwich
I'll let you know here in town please I
would love to get a sandwich with you
yeah man the edits on your pod are
incredible you see like the edits in my
pod you should check out Sarge's Deli a
lot of people are a cat's Deli and
Sarge's is good Mark and I have been
Sergeant is my favorite pastrami in the
city okay really yeah you go brown
mustard I don't do mustard uh you know
what I do I uh I get a potato pancake
and I dip it in applesauce oh the whole
thing come on it's [__] weird dude I
got you know that's [__] up but I'll
tell you something what the [__] I take
a green pill when I'm doing that you
better believe it that'll rule you're
gonna take a blue pill or if you ever
want to see your dick get hard again
after eating that food right there don't
take a red pill it'll be on Andrew
Tate's pod you guys are really good at
what you do oh come on well I'm off let
me tell you something your mother has
never told you oh God
I I I wouldn't do what you do because
that's not who I am but I really respect
what you do and I think no she did I was
[__] around
she's very good she's a fan she she
comes to shows no no I would I did a
thing during the pandemic
yeah those are actually hers you took
them out I'm not gonna get the feeling
when they're inside her so just get my
fix in now is that real you got you got
your mama breast well my mom's from
today's what's the most expensive thing
you bought somebody a member of your
family jeez I don't know I gave my
brother a kidney
Is that real well actually oh I [__]
that up I I took his kid
completely different things what are you
doing you like this you check out more
episodes of Are We drunk next week
we might be drunk we have a comedian
Bill Bellamy when's this Bethlehem uh in
York Pennsylvania this weekend I got uh
Toronto JFL uh the September 21st
Chicago Theater September 30th Phoenix
um [__] all over the place and you
just played over Madison Square how'd
that go that's November Cleveland uh
Columbus Cincinnati and Minneapolis uh
I'll be there where are you playing uh
the Mimi Ohio Theater
and so narcissistic
[Music]
do you know that venue I don't but I'm
sure down Cleveland uh after New York is
the biggest theater because Broadway's
first stop when they tour is Cleveland
it's a very big I went to I went to see
uh a show there once they have really
old beautiful beautiful so I'm not sure
which one that is but I bet you it's
awesome God what did I see though look
at that time we played I just I was just
playing hilarities this past weekend and
I don't remember who it was but somebody
there said how that you were that they
love you there and they want you to come
back but I think he's too big to do that
now I might pop in I love uh Nick and
Sam and everyone yeah over there it's
just it's one of the best clubs in the
country yeah great great just gonna say
great food and you're not shy about
giving it away either they're great yeah
they're great dudes there's your
Broadway it's just a classic it's a
classic Club yeah it's like a cool man
that's so cool that you guys play
theaters
and the big one is the MSG theater
November 4th New York City [__]
come out hell yeah
yeah we'll see you in hell I'm doing
I'll be in Europe when this comes out so
come out Lisbon Dublin Amsterdam
Copenhagen Glasgow Berlin uh uh
Manchester London Birmingham
antorp come on it's gonna be a Whopper
say hello queef it up yeah I'm coming to
DC Hershey uh what else we got
Cincinnati Louisville Chesterville
Missouri Springfield Missouri all kinds
of fun stuff Oklahoma City Dallas
Portland Providence Cleveland we're
buying Cleveland the Agora ooh I've been
there before it's fun Denver Denver
Denver Grand Rapids Grand Junction
Mobile Alabama Mobile Alabama Nola hello
Sacramento Santa Rosa Omaha how much how
much new do you think from like from
Notting the special are you on right now
I got about 25 wait what was the
question how like he just had a special
come out yeah but what did you ask how
much is brand new from the show beating
the show that you're doing now yeah but
this is September so I bet I'll have 35
40 by then yeah but is is the other 20
25 from your special or brand new yeah
no I'm confused what you're asking I was
asking like how much brand new stuff
isn't it all new
well you know you gotta you gotta lean
on the old [__] for a second I mean he
just had one come out but what I'm
saying is are you you're still doing a
half hour of the stuff that was on your
special no I've been riffing crowd
working yeah that's new it's not great I
have jokes but everybody told me that
last time we did this yeah like people
saw you like oh that's you're like get
the process I know it's not I hate that
I like to go out it's killing you got to
keep I mean I'm thinking I was gonna
tape like January February and I just
pushed my next special tape into March I
think there you go where are you doing
it Boston Wilbur yeah that's what I'm
gonna do it smart hold on
oh
oh my wife uh girlfriend fart sorry
all right well that's a good way to end
it love you Rick Rick you're the man
[Music]
we might
be true
[Music]